gleichzeitig an den fünf tagen in der eu
am 27 28 29
dezember das ist eine sehr gute
möglichkeit dieses schwierige jahr zu
beenden und tatsächlich ein neues blatt
aufzuschlagen mit 19
das ist unser erster impfstoff weitere
impfstoffe werden bald zugelassen falls
sie sich als unbedenklich und wirksam
ereignen die ema wird ein gutachten zum
2 im stoff veröffentlichen zu moderner
und das am 06
januar haben während wir die impfstoffe
für die europäer ausliefern
helfen wir auch dabei die impfstoffe für
die übrige welt sicherzustellen team
europe ist der größte beitragen euro und
zwar zur produktion für länder mit
geringen und mittleren einkommen
abschließend darf ich noch sagen wie
stolz ich bin der erste 19 impfstoff
verfügbar in europa ein wirkliches
produkt europäischer innovation ist
feiertag hat mehr als neun millionen
euro in bezug auf forschungsmittel in
der letzten dekade erhalten um diese
wirklich bahnbrechenden technologien zu
entwickeln und hat sich eine darlehen in
höhe von 100 millionen der europäischen
investitionsbank gesichert der von der
europäischen gestützt wird
damit konnten die
herstellungskapazitäten und
entwicklungskapazitäten auch weltweite
schnell aufgebaut werden und das ist
eine wirkliche europäische
erfolgsgeschichte vielen dank dafür
mehr nachrichten